muy buen día hay mucho hermetismo en
torno a estas negociaciones luego de
cuatro años de congelamiento y se
marcaría así el reinicio formal de los
diálogos de paz entre la guerrilla del
Ln y el gobierno colombiano lo que se
sabe hasta el momento es que va a ser en
el hotel Humboldt será la sede de este
encuentro unitel ubicado en la cima del
Cerro el Ávila será en horas de la tarde
pero ya los equipos negociadores se
encuentran en territorio venezolano
arribaron la tarde de este domingo y en
esta oportunidad destaca la presencia de
el presidente ejecutivo de la federación
colombiana de ganaderos que va a
participar en estas negociaciones siendo
uno de los sectores más afectados y
también llama la atención por ser una
persona bastante crítica a la
administración de Gustavo Petro él decía
que venía a representar amplios sectores
de Colombia y no solo al centro
democrático ti Patiño también formaría
parte de la delegación que viene del
gobierno colombiano quien es un
militante del m-19 por parte del Ln
también ya están en territorio
venezolano Pablo Beltrán segundo al
mando de la insurgencia Aureliano
carbonell miembro de la dirección
Nacional de la guerrilla Silvana
Guerrero Consuelo Tapia Isabel Torres
entre otros por supuesto Danilo Rueda el
alto comisionado para la paz consultado
precisamente sobre las expectativas de
este proceso al embajador de Colombia en
Venezuela Armando Benedetti él decía que
la guerrilla debe entender que es el
momento para concretar avances pero sin
embargo no podrían ponerle tiempo a
estas conversaciones ponía como ejemplo
que con el caso de La FARC duraron tres
años Pues quién sabe si esto podría
durar tres años más la prensa está
convocada para este encuentro en horas
de la tarde del día de hoy que
recordemos estos diálogos tenían cuatro
años congelados y finalmente se
reanudaron